Everyone knows dry ice is super cold,
and our Mega Solar Scorcher is super hot.
So what happens if they go up
against each other in a battle?
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
Guys, we've had literally hundreds,
possibly thousands of
comments asking to see
what happens if we pit dry ice
against our Mega Solar Scorcher.
So today, that is what we're doing.
Here's the basic idea.
We will take the Solar Scorcher
and we'll focus it right
on the surface of the dry ice.
After that, we'll try taking some dry ice,
breaking it up into a powder,
and focusing the solar scorcher on that.
We will then try
focusing it on lead, on pennies,
and on a steel plate
sitting on top of the dry ice
to see which one wins,
the extreme cold of the dry ice,
or the extreme heat of the Mega Solar Scorcher.
I have a good setup on our Solar Scorcher,
so we should be able to set
things down right where we want them.
And focus the beam right where we want it,
without having to hold on to it too long.
I've got some welding glasses
so I can look carefully and focus the point
right where I want it for maximum heat.
I think at this point,
we just have to try it.
Our old Solar Scorcher frame
had started to break down
and the lens had gotten cloudy.
So this is our new frame and our new lens,
the all new Mega Solar Scorcher 2.0.
We're going to try and break
this block of dry ice in half,
and we'll put half of it under the beam,
and we'll put half of it
off to the side as a control,
so we can see the difference
of having the light focused on it,
or not focused on it.
Just like with the mini solar scorcher,
this bolt works as a marker
to show us when it's focused.
It's perfectly perpendicular to our screen,
so once we get the shadow
to disappear completely,
we know that we've got
our lens pointed right at the sun.
Dry ice reflects a lot of light.
It's very white.
So it may not retain the heat very well.
That's why this is an experiment.
Let's find out what happens.
Got my welding goggles,
normal sunglasses.
Don't cut it.
Here it goes.
We have a dot focused right
on the surface of that dry ice.
It definitely looks like there's
more vapors coming off of the brick
that has the sunlight focused on it.
Just as a quick test
to show that this is hot,
I'm gonna stick a stick
right in that focal point.
[Music]
And the stick is burning and it's on fire.
Well there you go.
About 2 seconds in
the sunlight to light on fire.
Very nice and hot.
Standing behind it here,
I'm gonna put my regular sunglasses on
because I'm not looking right at point,
but just that whole brick
of dry ice is just glowing.
A lot of the light is
shining right down through it.
Just getting near.
It's so warm.
Over here, not so much.
Here's the block of dry ice that was sitting
in the focal point of our solar death ray.
And here's the block of ice that was
just sitting off to the side as a control,
and they look the same.
The one that was in the focal
point really hasn't changed much.
It didn't seem to sublimate
any noticeable amount faster.
For the most part,
I'm gonna say that the heat
from the Solar Scorcher didn't do much,
and it was sitting in that
focal point for about 20 minutes.
I think the solid white nature
of this hard Carbon Dioxide
just isn't much affected
by the heat from our Solar Scorcher.
Let's try taking a piece of the dry ice,
crushing it into powder,
and seeing that does anything
when focused under the lens.
[Music]
That looks like a pretty
good pile of dry ice powder.
Let's focus our death ray on it,
and see if it does anything.
There we go.
Beautifully in the focal point.
Wood, lights almost instantly.
Dry ice, lights less.
[Music]
After 15 minutes of our dry ice powder
sitting under the solar scorcher, it's...
It's just powder.
Nothing's really happens to it.
It may have sublimated a
little bit faster than normal,
but now we know that for the most part,
a solar scorcher focused on some
dry ice powder won't do too much to it.
Next up, there are three types of metal.
We're gonna test
as a control without dry ice.
This is a plate of steel,
these are some lead fishing sinkers,
and this is a penny.
This penny is from 2011,
which means it's mostly made of zinc,
with a thin copper coating.
All right, ready?
There we go.
Penny in the focal point.
And it's destroyed.
That took all of about
three seconds to be completely ruined.
Oh.
Oh! And now, it's doing something else,
I think the Zinc is actually burning
from the heat of the solar scorcher.
I don't want to breathe that in.
Oh, I can't really push it any more
because this penny is actually liquid.
Sweet. Love it.
Alright, this time, I have a stack of pennies,
and I'm just gonna slide
those right into the focal point.
The height makes it so
it's not quite as focused.
But that top penny has
still already been destroyed.
[Music]
This is now a barely
contained pile of molten metal.
I'm just gonna smoosh it. Smoosh.
The pennies melted very easily.
And now, we're going to try lead,
which actually has a much lower melting point,
so I suspect this is
gonna go almost instantly.
It is bubbling, and it is melted.
Yep, took just a couple of seconds,
and that thing is
just liquid, liquid, liquid,
runny silver metal.
Well pennies and lead
just liquefied in seconds.
Let's try something
a little bit more resistant,
a plate of steel.
Now, the Solar scorcher does
not get hot enough to liquefy this.
But I'm betting we see
a little bit of deformation,
maybe some discoloration.
And overall, it is going to get hot.
[Music]
Well there's the
discoloration I was talking about.
[Music]
Steel plate is nice and hot.
Let's drip some water on it
and watch what happens.
[Music]
Just immediately, skitters right off,
Leidenfrost full in effect.
[Music]
Boiling instantly.
Let's take that plate off
and see what it looks like.
We did get deformation.
That plate is not flat anymore.
It's not terribly warped,
but it's changed shape a bit.
We've now seen what happens,
focusing the full power
of our solar scorcher on pennies,
on some lead sinkers,
and on a steel plate.
Let's see what happens if we place
each of those on top of dry ice,
and then focus our death ray on it.
Our penny has lined up nicely
with where the focal point will be.
It's sitting on the dry ice.
And at this point, it is extremely cold.
Let's learn what happens
if we add a little bit of heat.
And by a little bit,
I mean a lot, a whole big lot.
[Music]
Penny is in the death ray.
At least very close to the death ray.
Now, it's in the death ray.
Oh it's spinning.
I didn't see that coming.
It's getting destroyed.
The surface of the
penny is bubbling and burning
the same way it did on the paver stone.
And now the penny,
because it got so hot,
is tunneling through the dry ice.
That is crazy.
Let's poke it with a stick, for Science.
That was amazing.
Let's try it with a stack of pennies.
[Music]
As the molten pennies
tunnel through the dry ice,
of course they somewhat leave
the focal point of the solar scorcher.
Interestingly, I think
a single penny tunneled a bigger hole
than a stack of five pennies.
All right, we are focused on the lead.
That is some bubbly warm metal.
Very very liquid.
As it's tunneling down through the dry ice,
some little bits of lead
are becoming separated from the rest.
And those parts are
solidifying again quite easily.
The lead melted super easily.
And once it was molten metal,
it tunneled down through
the dry ice pretty quickly.
We've got some great cavities,
both from where the pennies were,
and from where the molten lead was.
Pouring some water down onto our plate,
it has cooled off to the point
that it no longer is evaporating quickly.
I kinda want to just leave
it here for a second longer
until it gets so cold again,
that all of that water freezes.
[Music]
The ice on our steel plate
has now frozen all the way through.
And I'm just gonna refocus
the solar scorcher on it
and see how long that ice stays solid.
Oh, I hear sizzling.
I think that ice is not
gonna stay ice for long.
It's gone.
So there's our steel plate being
hit with the full force of our solar scorcher,
sitting on top of a block of dry ice.
Which do you think is gonna win?
Do you think the plate will get hot?
Or do you think it's gonna stay cold?
[Music]
A steel plate, that just a minute ago was so
cold that water froze in a matter of seconds,
now just boils that water almost instantly.
In a direct fight,
the solar scorcher versus the dry ice,
the Solar Scorcher didn't
seem to have much power at all.
But when you had an intermediary, of a metal,
it really seemed to kick the dry ice's [inaudible].
What do you guys think?
Do you think the dry ice won?
Or the solar scorcher won?
Guys, that's not all we've got for you.
This little box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
And the box at the bottom will show you
what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
Not to mention that
this bomb here in the center
will subscribe you to our channel,
so you never miss out on a video again.
Don't forget to ring that bell.
And we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.